Quick reminder that we have more detailed maps
of the surface of Mars than the Earth's ocean
floor. In fact, there's a map for that. This is
a map that highlights in dark blue what part of
the ocean floor is still unmapped. It also shows
the percentage of unmapped territory on the shores
of different countries. Japan's doing pretty
good. They've mapped most of their ocean floor,
while Thailand has barely mapped any of their
ocean. And the U.S. still has about a third of
its oceans unmapped. The ocean makes up
like 70% of the Earth's surface. So why
don't we have a good map of the majority
of our planet? It comes down to a lack of
will. It's not like it's crazy expensive. It
would cost an estimated $3 billion to create
a detailed map of the entire ocean floor.
That's like a rounding error for, like,
the US military or Jeff Bezos. NASA's spent around
that much, $3 billion, to send the Perseverance
Rover to Mars, and billions more on previous Mars
missions. Which, I get it. That's really useful,
fascinating stuff. But wouldn't it be equally
so to discover what our own planet looks like?